Look down at your body.
Some of that stuff
doesn't do anything,
and I'm about to call it out.
Get ready.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, guys.
Trace here chatting
from DNews in DC.
Your body is filled with
genetic and biological garbage.
Not just the junk
DNA we've talked
about in the past
but actual structures
that your body took the
time to put together.
And they don't do anything.
A couple of new studies just
completed by researchers
at Boston University
and the University
of Liverpool
focused on our feet.
Take off your shoe and try and
bend your foot in the middle.
The average human foot should
only bend in one place,
at the ball.
But 1 out of every
13, at least, can
bend a second joint in
their foot just like chimps.
Everyone's got that joint.
But a lot of us,
we can't bend it,
because our bodies
added a tough ligament
once we started walking upright.
Those with softer
ligaments, they
can bend their foot like me.
Not Anthony, though,
and he's jealous.
And that's not all.
That's just one of the things
that you can do at parties.
Genetic stuff we once
needed that is now
irrelevant or
non-functional is called
vestigial, a vestige of
our evolutionary past.
Leftovers like the second foot
joint are all over in our DNA.
The appendix was useful
at one point, for example,
but now it's just
kind of chilling.
Some primates have
appendices and use them
to digest tough
cellulose, but we really
don't eat that anymore.
So now we don't need it.
Over the generations
of humans, it's
become slowly less pronounced.
But it's still present like an
evolutionary intestinal time
bomb.
Another is this vestigial tail.
It's just one of
those weird things
that our DNA gives embryos
as a genetic leftover.
But usually, they're given the
command to die by the genes
while you're still in the womb.
But rarely we make
it through birth
with this vestigial extension.
If you're still in
doubt about evolution,
then combine the tail with
a condition called lanugo,
or a fine growth of hair
that can develop on a fetus.
And it sometimes is
present at birth.
So we have tails and we're
covered in fur at birth,
and somehow we didn't
evolve from animals?
Get out of town.
We have a whole other host of
vestigial items-- goosebumps,
tonsils, wisdom teeth,
and other things left over
from when we had fur.
We had more primitive
immune systems,
and we used
cellulose-based diets.
My favorite, though--
our third eyelid.
We have a vestigial third
eyelid just like reptiles, guys.
It was designed to
keep the eyeball moist
and to protect it.
And now we put that baby in a
corner, genetically speaking.
What is an evolutionary
trait that you
wish we hadn't dropped?
There are a bunch of lists
online if none of these
tickle your fancy.
Or just, you know, let
us know in the comments.
Thanks for watching
DNews, everyone,
and keep your DNA clean, OK.